one of America's most prized fish is at
the center of a fight between
conservationists and the federal
government the Trump administration
extended the red snapper season for
recreational fishing in the Gulf of
Mexico last month burn mental groups
filed a lawsuit claiming that extension
jeopardizes efforts to rebuild the snap
the red snapper population Omar
Villafranca is in Dulac Louisiana with
more on the story Omar good morning good
morning fishermen from Texas to Florida
want to see this fish on the end of
their line this is a red snapper and so
far off the Louisiana coast fishermen
have caught more than 327 tons of the
fish and that number is expected to go
up
Dale Beebe is a commercial fisherman who
just returned to the Louisiana Shore
with almost six thousand pounds of one
of the most sought-after fish in the
Gulf of Mexico red snapper it has been
great we've had the best snapper fishing
in the last the snapper is prized in
restaurants as flaky and full of flavor
and on fishing boats it's renowned for
its fight this year the Department of
Commerce extended the red snapper season
for recreational fishing in federal
waters from just three days to 42 the
department said the three-day season was
hurting businesses that depend on sport
fishing a commercial fisherman worried
longer seasons could threaten the red
snapper population overfishing caused
the Gulf's red snapper population to
plummet in the mid-1980s David croissant
of the coastal conservation Association
of Louisiana says the red snapper
population has largely recovered and a
three-day fishing season is too short
for recreational anglers two of those
days here in Louisiana were on fishermen
the weather was too rough this year the
government set a quota of just over 13
million pounds of red snapper to be
pulled from the Gulf 51 percent for
commercial fishermen 49 percent for
recreational but in 2016
recreational anglers exceeded that limit
by
65 tonnes if you're not going to adhere
to the law why have regulations David
crebbs owns Ariel seafoods a large
seafood supply chain we can all just go
back to the wild wild west so and it is
gonna damage the resource right now
we're in a federal season
JP Brooker is an attorney for the Ocean
Conservancy a group suing the federal
government to limit the extended fishing
season it's fundamentally unfair it's
unfair to commercial fishermen it's
unfair to the long-term viability of the
recreational fishery as well but others
argue the regulations have to be fair
including to those who fish for fun we
all want to protect the resource but
there's got to be a balance between
protecting the resource watching it grow
and still allowing it to be available to
the American public what's happening
here on the Louisiana Gulf Coast and all
the Gulf Coast states is part of a
series of changes in the trump
administration that's being challenged
by environmental groups over in
Yellowstone National Park the grizzly
bear is actually about to be removed for
the endangered species list and if the
government doesn't abandon their plans
to remove the bear from the list
environmental groups say they will sue
Nora Omar thank you they're holding the
fish beautiful fish that snapper as
never I do too well we learn a lot after
this season I think about the effects